celebration of more than 30 years of
independence from the old Soviet Union
and more than a hundred years of freedom
from the Russian Empire
but today even Georgia's president
questioned how free her country is to
pursue its stated goal of European
integration
every day statements and actions
distance us from Europe and lead us
towards isolation
the question arises where did the words
Europe is our civilized Choice disappear
last week Georgia saw the first direct
flight from Moscow in four years despite
Russia's continued occupation of 20 of
Georgian territory and its military
invasion of Ukraine
protesters said it was a gift from Putin
for the government's cooperation with
the Russian Federation
shame on you this woman said
that cooperation has included the ending
of visa restrictions to Russia for
Georgian citizens
some appreciate this latest sign of
ditant
I have a son and a wife who live in
Russia every time I have to get a visa
and if I don't have to go through that
procedure anymore why not
Washington and Brussels have criticized
tibilisi for resuming flights with
Moscow given Georgia's official bid to
join the EU his latest decision by
Georgian authorities concerns races
raises concerns in terms of Georgia's EU
path the war but Georgia says it needs
to perform a delicate Balancing Act
between Russia and the West we have
maintained secured peace and stability
this is the most important thing in my
job and my duty
is to protect the national interests of
my country
is to protect our people
these protesters wanted to remind the
authorities that over 80 percent of
Georgians see their future in the EU but
their passage was blocked we come here
with big European flags to tell them
that we are Georgians and we need Iraq
and we believe that Georgian place is in
Europe
this is supposed to be a day of unity
for Georgians where they come together
to celebrate their country's
Independence
it's cheer there were e-flags
prominently just
this year
people waving their EU flags and not
being allowed through police lines times
have changed
that Georgia is a Sovereign Nation free
to make its own choices isn't really in
doubt what is in doubt is the direction
in which Georgia is heading Robin for
SDA Walker Al Jazeera tibilisi